an unexpected discovery founded over a
thousand years ago venice italy is a
treasure trove of history but some of it
has yet to come to the surface literally
as chris livesay tells us low tide in
the venetian lagoon can reveal wonders
of the past even as rising waters
threaten the city's future
you may think you've seen venice
turns out that's just the tip of the
iceberg says mourinho rosie a fisherman
turned amateur archaeologist
these 220 square miles of surrounding
lagoon are gurgling with medieval even
roman ruins like this olive mill it's
there just a few feet beneath the
surface so many underwater riches you
can trip over them
the island of santa andrea is one of
dozens that used to be a medieval
monastery wow so this is where the monks
in the monastery would live and they
would pray before it sank but the tide
is a time machine he says when it's low
it takes you back even further to the
romans who fled the barbarian invasions
i'm i'm just shocked that we can reach
down and pick this up this piece of
ancient roman history is right here for
anybody to just pick up with their bare
hands if it only ended there but these
islands were once a burial ground for
plague victims and the rising sea level
is a grave robber so now human remains
from the plague are just washing up on
the shore
climate change is swallowing venice
flooding the city more frequently and
severely than ever but it's also laying
waste to its lagoon burying its island
treasures so deep they may soon be
forever out of reach
to capture it american artist alison
zerflu is in a race against time i love
to paint the lagoon because i think it's
beautiful
but sometimes when i'm painting out here
i think
it it comes to me so
so strong you're painting before it's
gone
you're painting it before it's gone
but it's more than just history that's
vanishing this was once a fisherman's
paradise so how's fishing changed
[Music]
but today domenico rossi says rising
temperatures have wrought an invasion of
jellyfish clogging his nets meant for
soft shell crab his catch is down some
40 percent this decade
my son wanted to be a fisherman he says
but i won't allow it there's no future
here an ecosystem landscape and way of
life each in its twilight
indeed this isn't just the local threat
to venice it's part of the global threat
of climate change scientists have long
warned coastal cities like new york
miami and los angeles to pay close
attention to this lagoon for cbs
saturday morning chris livesay venice
oh venice still makes me want to go to
venice yes
wonderful memories and such lessons yeah